Beh Innanzitutto grazie per l'invito per
chi fa il mio mestiere una delle prime
cose e la didattica e capire come
insegnare agli studenti in questo caso
io ho capito come si possono apprendere
molte cose Vi ringrazio tantissimo per
tutto quello che ho che ho potuto
comprendere questa sera come come
sono stato presentato da quello che ha
detto Pino io non devo parlarvi del
presente non Devo farvi una proposta per
il futuro e forse neppure dare un
messaggio
per mettere le cose a posto Io devo
parlare di un mestiere che è quello
dello storico e di devo parlarvi di una
cosa che non esiste che il passato
Che cosa fa lo storico Innanzitutto
Cerca di comprendere di costruire di si
pone dei problemi si fa delle domande e
cerca di in un qualche modo impostare
queste domande con il passato e cerca di
trovare un modo affinché il passato
risponda e in un qualche modo offra una
storia o fra uno scenario un
palcoscenico dove collocare un racconto
ovviamente il passato non risponde Il
passato non può dirti quello che pensa
difficilmente dice la verità e quindi lo
storico deve trovare un modo per
interrogarlo e soprattutto deve trovare
un modo per far parlare il passato
quello è quello è questo è il nostro
mestiere quello che cerchiamo di fare e
negli ultimi tempi Forse in questa fase
della nostra storia cerchiamo di farlo
con una complessità molto più grande
perché il passato È tornato ed è tornato
in proporzioni che non si vedevano o
forse che non si erano mai viste oggi
dovunque a partire da un posto come
questo vediamo che il passato ci parla
ci sono manifestazioni Ci sono eventi ci
sono presentazioni di libri credo che
ognuno di voi che vive in un paese del
mezzogiorno d'Italia d'Europa non passa
un'estate in cui non vede una
ricostruzione in costume storico un
episodio di folklore un modo con cui il
passato torna e perché il passato è
tornato in maniera Così così grandi uno
perché vi ha molto di più prima si
viveva molto poco nell'epoca in cui si
collocano i miei studi Si viveva fino a
più o meno con un'età media di 29 anni
un quarto della popolazione viveva costa
meno fino a 5 anni generalmente si
moriva di malattie contagiose per
esempio i tumori c'è quella parola che
oggi ci turbano tanto
ci turba tanto quanto arriva i tumori
erano una malattia difficile perché si
moriva molto presto Oggi sì l'età media
in Italia tra l'altro tra i paesi più
avanzati e 85 anni abbiamo molto tempo a
disposizione abbiamo una cosa che le
generazioni precedenti non avevano il
tempo libero e Questo spiega perché il
passato è tornato perché Innanzitutto
torna nelle nostre vite e tornando il
passato nelle nostre vite diventa anche
un attore collettivo e quindi noi ci
troviamo in questa doppia situazione da
un lato di far parlare il passato
consapevole che non ti rispondi che non
ti risponde devi interloquire con lui e
dall'altro lato con un passato che
invece torna in vite lunghe invita e
piena di tempo e con un bisogno sempre
più grande di comprendere che cosa sia
il passato
Focus a questo si colloca il nostro
mestiere e si colloca il modo con cui
noi cerchiamo di confrontarci con cui
c'è noi cerchiamo di far parlare il
passato e cerchiamo di farlo nella
maniera più accettabile possibile cioè
cerchiamo il verosimile perché sappiamo
che la verità storica la verità assoluta
Non esiste e in questa in questo senso
in questa direzione provo a fare gli
degli esempi prova a fargli degli esempi
parlarne parlandovi di uno degli
elementi fondamentali di chi studia il
passato che il tempo
perché quando ci interroghiamo Su che
cosa sia il passato ci poniamo un
problema molto grande Cioè come
misuriamo La forza del tempo e come
misuriamo il senso del tempo
il tempo non è uguale o meglio dal punto
di vista cronologico dal punto di vista
della misurazione i vecchi storici
parlavano della scansione secolare del
tempo dal punto di vista della
misurazione dei minuti che servono per
far passare questo spazio di un
intervento Il passato è uguale ma il
passato non è uguale rispetto alla
intensità con cui si vivono un momento
storico per esempio la parola che prima
io ho usato la parola tumore se in una
famiglia sei una persona rimbalza questa
parola il senso di del tempo il momento
in cui Questo arriva l'intensità con cui
un dramma tocca una famiglia tocco un
individuo rende quel momento quello
spazio quel tempo molto più pesante
molto più forte molto più rapido
E questo vale per mille cose una
rivoluzione una guerra un sindaco che si
dimette arriva il commissario e bisogna
fare la battaglia politica per
conquistare il comune in un comune le
persone che non facevano politica
iniziano a farlo anche in un piccolo
centro e il tempo di chi cerca le
famiglie numerose per fare le liste o di
chi cerca i candidati cambia di peso ed
è il peso del tempo quello in cui io
collo con la risposta alla domanda che
c'è stata posta dagli organizzatori come
metti una voragine nel passato una
vertigine nel passato come una vertigine
rende il tempo più pesante come una
vertigine può spiegare un passato rapido
un passato più intenso un passato più
drammatico proviamo a fare degli esempi
scelgo tre protagonisti tre momenti
storici rapidissimi sono tre fatti di
maggiore e minore importanza che in un
qualche modo riconosciamo nei nostri
processi storici tre uomini Cortez Il
Duca di Wellington e Carlo Pisacane
Cortez Come forse Ovviamente tutti
quanti sapete e questo personaggio
incredibile
voluttuoso prepotente aggressivo geniale
e violento che trasformò la storia del
mondo unificando l'Atlantico e il
Mediterraneo nella costruzione del
grande impero degli Asburgo
nel 1519 la storia della conquista del
Messico si basa su un principio
fondamentale cioè mise tutti quelli che
erano contro gli Aztechi e chiodi amano
gli Aztechi furono raccolti da Cortes
per distruggere l'impero degli Aztechi
Nel giugno del
1520 Cortese era nella capitale degli
Aztechi che si chiamava trottigan e a un
certo punto
le forze che in un qualche modo avevano
cercato di difendere l'impero azteco
dall'invasione Europea siqurizzarono
rifiutarono l'imperatore Montezuma che
aveva accettato col test e cercarono di
eliminare gli spagnoli e i loro alleati
che stavano occupando il centro di
quella che adesso è Città del Messico
all'epoca era radionotica Anna
si arriva alla notte del 30 giugno del
1520 c'è la vertigine più brutale gli
spagnoli non sono riusciti a scappare
dalla città i loro alleati gli dicono
che devono andare via prima che sia
troppo tardi gli amici di Cortex gli
suggeriscono di difendere la città o
meglio di chiudersi nella città fino a
quando arrivano gli altri spagnoli e
questa la vertigine della decisione più
drammatica Cortes deve scegliere se
restare aspettare che arrivano gli amici
o andare via lui decide di andare via e
quella che diventerà la noce triste la
notte triste buona parte degli Spagnoli
degli alleati vengono uccisi molti altri
vengono presi prigionieri e verranno poi
sacrificati a mangiati sulle torri della
capitale degli Aztechi ma Cortez riesce
a fuggire per tornare
la vertigine di quella notte drammatica
la decisione cambia la storia della sua
vita ma soprattutto cambia la storia del
mondo quando meno di un anno dopo col
test ritornerà nella capitale degli
Aztechi la conquisterà e farà
dell'impero degli Asburgo il primo
Impero globale della storia del mondo
spostiamoci di diversi anni se va avanti
se non va avanti ve ne parlo va bene e
andiamo torniamo indietro e andiamo in
Belgio a Bruxelles a un po' di
chilometri di brusselli e una Piana che
con un nome che un po' tutti potete
ricordare che Waterloo
su questa Piana che adesso Tra l'altro
si può visitare bellissimo e chi vuole
fare un giro di fronte alle colline di
Mont Saint Jean così si chiamano queste
di Waterloo
arriva dopo la sua fuga dall'isola
d'Elba Napoleone Bonaparte in quelli che
sono i cento giorni gli ultimi 100
giorni del grande impero il comandante
dell'esercito alleato dell'esercito
della restaurazione che deve fermare
Napoleone Bonaparte era il Duca di
Wellington Il Duca di Wellington era
stato sconfitto due giorni prima proprio
da Napoleone in un posto che si chiama
catro Bra Il 16 giugno del 1815 si era
ritirato su queste colline e aspettava
l'arrivo dei Prussiani dei suoi alleati
di un generale che si chiama broker per
affrontare Napoleone però Napoleone
arriva inizia quella che diventa la
battaglia di Waterloo Ci sono mille
episodi fino a quando si arriva al
pomeriggio blucher non è arrivato
e Napoleone in un qualche modo
riesce a conquistare il centro del campo
di battaglia e lancia questo lo racconto
in libri bellissimi
di umana e Victor Hugo raccontava i
libri bellissimi e Lancia prima la sua
Cavalleria e poi la vecchiaia la guardia
contro Wellington Wellington deve
decidere se aspettare il broker e
ritirarsi su Bruxelles oppure
fare i quadrati della sua fanteria e
cercare di fermare Napoleone e questo
può cambiare il suo destino può cambiare
il destino dei suoi eserciti Ma dal suo
punto di vista soprattutto cambiare il
destino dell'Europa
Wellington lo decide Napoleone viene
fermato la sera sul campo di battaglia i
Prussiani arrivano la vecchia guardia e
poi la grande armata viene Travolta
dalla storia d'Europa finisce Napoleone
che va nell'Isola in cui morirai a quei
Manzoni dedicherà la sua famosa poesia È
Wellington nella vertigine del
pomeriggio di Waterloo è riuscito a
cambiare
la storia d'Europa è sicuramente la
storia del mondo occidentale
scegliamo una storia più piccola
un'altra vertigine un uomo di minore
taglia meno conosciuto nella storia del
mondo però forse in un qualche modo
importante per la storia del Mezzogiorno
era un napoletano un ufficiale Borbonico
aveva disertato era diventato un
mazziniano un repubblicano aveva
partecipato alla grande rivoluzione
italiana e vissuto mille storie anche di
tipo sentimentale che in un qualche modo
le avevano già trasformate in una specie
di manifesto del Romanticismo italiano
si chiamava Carlo Pisacane a un certo
punto lui Mazzini e molti altri si
convincono che bisogna ricominciare la
rivoluzione quella che era stata persa
nel 1848 49 e bisogna ricominciarla da
sud dal mezzogiorno
organizzano questa spedizione tutti sono
contrari la sinistra del risorgimentale
quella che era Capitanata da Garibaldi
considera una pazzia la spedizione di
Pisacane Ma alla fine lui decide di
partire questo avviene il 25 giugno del
la sua compagna quella che ha
abbandonato il marito per seguirlo nella
fuga l'ha abbandonato il marito i figli
cerca disperatamente di convincerlo a
non partire tutti i suoi amici dicono
che la morte è certa con il linguaggio
che si usava all'epoca e lui decide di
farlo ma decide di farlo lasciando un
testamento entrerà nella storia del
Risorgimento italiano come il testamento
politico di Carlo Pisacane
in cui lui che cosa dice dice qual è la
sua vertigine e quella di partire per
morire
lui è consapevole è abbastanza
consapevole di non avere speranza e
consapevole è abbastanza consapevole
della disperazione in cui si muove la
sua impresa Eppure nella sua vertigine
c'è la convinzione che in questo modo
lui esisterà
lui diventerà quello che poi l'800 il
Risorgimento italiano riconosceranno
Carlo Pisacane e quindi tre vertigini
per vedere come lo storico che cerca
l'intensità la drammaticità il momento
in cui qualcuno deve
decidere cosa fare nella forma più
intensa e più drammatica possibile
Cortese che sceglie di fuggire per
tornare
nella capitale dell'impero dell'impero
azteco Wellington che sceglie di
resistere per vincere contro il grande
imperatore Pisacane che sceglie di
partire per morire per Risorgimento
italiano rispondono alla domanda
Esistono le vertigini nella storia Certo
ne esistono tantissime e la loro
drammaticità è legata al momento
alla intensità e al modo con cui l'uomo
vive la sua scelta
nella fase forse più drammatica della
sua vita questo ci dice anche un'altra
cosa rispetto al mestiere dello storico
il mestiere dello storico quando Cerca
anche i momenti più difficili i momenti
più drammatici quando Cerca anche le
vertigini
a due cose
a due elementi deve sempre tenere conto
innanzitutto che chi fa la storia non sa
come va a finire
quando Noi studiamo la storia
abbiamo la necessità di comprendere che
le persone che in un qualche modo
cerchiamo di analizzare di studiare di
raccontare a differenza nostra non sanno
come va a finire la storia e non
possiamo dire a loro quello che hanno
sbagliato o quello che noi vogliamo che
loro facessero perché la loro storia è
quella che si sviluppa che cresce che
diventa una vestigine ma di cui non
potevano conoscere L'esito che invece
noi conosciamo secondo e chiudo nel
mestiere dello storico non basta Non
dire alla storia quello che deve che non
doveva fare o quello che doveva essere
ma c'è una cosa ancora più importante
che proprio legata al ritorno così
impetuoso della storia dei nostri 30
anni di quelli che dicono vi racconto
una storia che nessuno vi ha mai
raccontato oppure di quegli altri che vi
dicono vi rivelo cose che vi erano state
nascoste questo non esiste questo è solo
un modo di cercare un protagonista di
cercare un palcoscenico il mestiere
dello storico ha chiaro una cosa che
forse la più importante di tutte che la
storia va lasciata al suo posto
che a volte drammatica a volte Cuba a
volte è triste a volte è noiosa molte
volte epica se resta lì dove e diventa
un'altra cosa diventa un racconto
vittimistico nostalgico a volte
Provinciale se togliamo la storia da
dove e la utilizziamo per un
protagonista politico giornalistico
mediatico del presente la storia è una
cosa bellissima se resta nel passato e
una cosa inutile se la usiamo
pubblicamente nel presente è un mestiere
che mi piace moltissimo Grazie
[Applauso]